here is brandon woodruff rock
he has been nothing but lights out for
craig council yeah look at the end run
average 158 that's good for second in
the national league i mean big strikeout
totals
for brandon all the numbers good except
for the win-loss record that's pretty
much not his fault
over his last four games since coming
off the il he's hitting it 786.
is that good that's really good
on the ground right side and that'll get
through into right field cronenworth
stops at second base
as abacio garcia gets to it quickly and
gets it back in but
padres have something going here he
demonstrates the swing on that base hit
into right field yeah he's telling wayne
kirby what he did watch him
work his hands inside this baseball the
fastball in
one two hit to a line
drive catch at third by luis
urias oswar didn't get it all
hit it fairly well but right at louis
cerriz
you look at blake snell he has had this
is his fifth
road start as well he's been excellent
the last two starts
both against colorado and if you look at
it 18 strikeouts to four walks
that is a key looking into tonight
swinging a miss and
kane strikes out the first k of the
night for blake snell two down
there it is don the change up finishing
off lorenzo kane
saw the grip three and two taylor waits
the pitch from stella swung on in miss
got him with a back foot slider and it
was filthy
a one two three first for blake with a
couple of strikeouts go to the second
inning in milwaukee no score blake's
staring in to get his sign from catcher
austin nola they go through a couple of
different ones now he's into the wind up
and the o2 pitch to garcia's swung on
and miss got him to chase a fastball
away
garcia literally just shaking his head
as he walks back to the dugout
and now three straight strikeouts for
blake snell breaking ball that time and
hara strikes out
gonna throw him out and nola will that
is four straight strikeouts for blake
snell two down here in the second inning
manny pina making his first appearance
since the royal series tough duty when
you're not playing a lot
stay sharp offensively let alone staying
sharp defensively not easy
pina drive deep center pro far
back to nothing milwaukee
the pineapple strikes in the second
that's got to feel good for manny pina
hasn't played in a while first at bat
a big fly and gives brandon woodruff a
two-to-nothing lead
a fastball after laying off the
change-up that was just off the plate
strength three called on the outside
corner
second strikeout for woodruff outside
corner at the top of the strike zone
struck him out 97 on the outside corner
shut down inning from brandon woodruff
featuring a couple of strikeouts back to
work on offense when we return
good speed at second with cronenworth
ground ball hit to the left side great
stop by adamus throws the first in time
and had base hit written all over it
but adam has stopped on a dime to get
his glove on it
yeah i mean well done i mean what an
athletic play that was by adamus
and over there covering the bag and had
to reverse his
momentum and able to get it as it goes
down on the ground and how about the
throw check out the throw flat-footed
kicks and deals fly ball to right
back garcia with room
getting over woodruff works around the
lead off single in the fourth
yeah watch him tap his glove on the
ground he doesn't loud enough to make
will myers think maybe a breaking ball
is coming so breaking ball maybe in the
back of his mind and then to go with the
fastball right on the outside corner and
him a little behind him
two nothing brewers bottom of the fourth
inning avi garcia
facing his former teammate in blake
snell two on pitch and garcia rips this
one
a high drive deep left by by baseball
my goodness did avi garcia get into that
one
it's three to nothing brewers
number eight on the season for garcia
he's homered in back-to-back games now
and that ball got way out of here
to left-center above the brewers bullpen
that ball was crushed 456 feet
plenty of traffic here on adamus and
pina
for colton wong coming off a three-hit
game yesterday in cincinnati
[Applause]
you talk about a big hit yeah it's a big
hit right there for colton wahl he
looked like blake snell one pitch away
from getting out of this inning
with only one run in the home run by
garcia but he hung a slider
and colten long able to weigh back on it
not a very good pitch but
wong able to take advantage of it and
driving a couple of runs with two outs
there's strike
if three slow going up then he's going
to ring you out yeah if he stands
straight up it means i don't like that
pitch
from what he had done at the end of 2018
the better part of 2019
had a good year last year teams know
about brandon woodruff now
strikes out o'grady a big zero for the
brewers
and their ace brandon woodruff
right-handed batter waiting
target on the inside by pina got him
looking and no argument from
fam on that one woodruff coming back
at 98. going back in there
grounded to first casting heroes got it
flips to woodruff
and another clean inning for brandon
woodruff
two balls and two strikes on hosmer
swinging a miss
he struck him out with 98.
brandon woodruff strikeout number seven
for woodruff
14 000 strong here in milwaukee
on pitch number 100 struck him out
seven scoreless for brandon woodruff
in this game fly ball headed to
deep left field off the bat at tommy fam
it's back and it is gone wow
long home run for tommy fam a two-run
shot
and the padres are on the board it's now
five to two a pro far walk and a blast
by
fam and it's 5-2 well he just beats him
to the spot
probably the best swing that tommy pham
has taken
josh hader in a save situation he's been
perfect this year rock and he's got to
have to go through fernando tatis
to start 2-2 struck him out
went
[Applause]
osmer sends this one to left field back
goes bradley junior it's going to be
over his head and one off the wall
conor is coming around he will score in
the second goes hosmer with a double
and the padres will bring the tying run
to the plate here in the ninth inning
it's now five to three
line drive left center field jackie
bradley junior's got it ball game over
and the brewers hang on for a 5-3 win
over san diego